you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing any
5-2 game let's try the French defense
and see what black throws at me on
exchange French with a quick c4 strike
okay I looked at this not too long ago
hmm Bishop e7 let's go with Bishop e7 I
don't want to take on c4 too early it's
Castle consider taking on c4 only after
the bishop moves and actually let me
deploy my nightie here a little bit
awkward to obstruct the C pawn but some
IDs in mind which is to say a capture
and then Bishop g4 do I go for that
right now capture on c4 and then play
Bishop g4 or Bishop g4 right away on
Bishop g4 h3 Bishop h5 g for Bishop g6
let me take right now yeah
Bishop takes c4 now we do this so I'm
threatening to take and then take here
okay yeah I'm recalling now there was
this move if Bishop e2 there was this
move up to be a okay so now what to do
there in a pen just a nice I think still
rook to b8 this move is good just
protecting b7 rook b8 on h3 I take the
knight take on d4 let's try this maybe
not such a good move okay it's thinking
they could push and then take on a 7 but
can I not just take the knight now and
then take on d4 I'm on there Queen
there's no time to pin my knight they
were really going to take with the pawn
oh they hesitated okay so that
hesitation tells me that they didn't
calculate this so I think they have to
just pitch the pond they can't if they
damage their structure like that that's
still like being up a pond maybe even
more might be exact it's exaggerating
some with that but you know direct
they're your own pond you're your own
king shelter like that double isolated F
pawns isolated H pawn what would I do if
they go for that they are going for that
Wow okay well what would I like to have
happen here
I'd like the dark square Bishop 16 in an
anchor Knight right on f4 and he will
bring the pain I could also look to play
Bishop d6 Bishop d6 Bishop g5 is a bit
awkward
hmm yeah I'm gonna chase I'm gonna chase
that Bishop away if he plays the g5
Bishop g3 at the
they'll take paan takes and they'll be
pretty weakened didn't consider that
what about Knight h5 focusing on these
squares here this is this these are the
squares they've weakened their Kings
side so Knight h5 and then Bishop here's
an idea
Knight each five Knight takes Bishop
Queen takes two knights versus two
bishops but they should be able to find
fine homes for my pieces no I don't want
to take their night
strains out their pawns I have to deal
with this let's try this move Queen h4
is an idea now as well you know there
should be right opening up my Queens
eyes to enter their weakened King
position I'm focusing on a weak square
f4 bishop here I cannot play this my
pawn is pinned on Bishop g5 I think just
Queen d7 be fine which is throwing a
punch actually striking at h3 I would
just like to see this it helps improve
my knight position blocks in there
Bishop
what might - they're taking there let's
recapture and develop also get over here
I'll be a little bit cautious of moving
this rook because of the pressure they
have on f7 so if some rook to the D file
it will be the B pond or the B rook I
don't need him there anymore to watch
over the V pond and maybe it's time to
transfer this Knight now not quite let's
get him working first okay now what
about Knight here to d5 let's do it
ship here I have checks as well let's
keep this in mind
Queen g6 maybe she gives check at some
point and target something along this
diagonal I have some indirect light
square control you might say with my
queen about Knight g6
yes focus on that f4 square Bishop takes
I'm going to take with the F pawn eyes
up these weak squares I'll be vulnerable
on this diagonal but I like the there's
too many positives not to take with the
off pawn I feel like the computer would
computer playing as black right now
would win this game within the next four
or five moves there should be something
really soon if you don't take it if they
don't take on g6 I mean they're gonna
have to tolerate a knight on f4 for the
remainder of the game and let's see how
you could tolerate a knight on F for the
remainder of the game or there's that
did not consider that one so they're
probably planning Knight f4 Bishop g4
okay um I could go with the night h4
mm-hmm I still just jump in now let's
get
Bishop g4 is going to be played now hmm
always just centralized at this rook
working even if both bishops are
exchanged for both Knights I should have
something in the major peace ending but
I kind of want to keep a knight on board
I think Bishop g4 you could challenge it
with f5 force Bishop takes Knight okay I
was ready to drop my knight with Queen
here let's do this
hmm okay didn't see that one
and now f5 I guess
okay I've weakened my dark squares I'd
like to get my King back over here
actually maybe f7 is the best square for
my king maybe I do this if they're not
careful Bishop - one of these - I think
let's go here get my queen here they
don't have a light square bishop let's
let's centralize my queen put her on a
light square Bishop h6 could be played
Queen d5 mm-hmm okay
that Bishop is really really annoying
let's go here there's a good move
Fon pushes otherwise I was going to go
here I wonder if I could have played
there one move sooner mm-hmm aye aye sir
we missed my opportunity to in this game
much sooner there must have been
something if we have all major pieces
exchanged would things look Knight g3 if
there isn't if they take with the pawn
also I could grab here although my King
is a little bit exposed should I grab
here I have enough control okay
Knight g3 check they're not afraid of
that at some point I could even consider
this okay they should still be good for
me even on time I have these squares
covered let's just go here hang on to
that H pawn rook here oh I could have
to check and then land at a fork mm all
right
I missed that idea night G 3 to eat ooh
hmm I have this square covered I could
take here night G 3 stuff let's just
back up clean f3 they're really short on
time so am i all right do something good
here
this battery oh man Oh too scary they're
down on time man this game should have
not even gotten to this point hmm well I
liked how I played the opening not a fan
of how it finished not the loss on time
by my opponent but you know it's one of
those positions where you just know
there's something there and the computer
will be lighting up with some type of
knockout mmm okay yeah as mentioned I
recently had a game yeah I don't know
how far back but remember looking at
this one with the stockfish 7 and it's
suggesting this idea of in this line
here where we have the exchanged French
just going with these uh natural moves
Bishop e7 castles and then this knight
c6 move putting pressure on d4 you have
to be a little bit careful as black
because this uh you know I've done this
before where you take after the bishop
has moved they recapture and then you
come out here
pin but you have to be careful of this
stuff where they break the pin like so
and then have a really strong knight on
e5 and then you always have to be
concerned of this type of stuff your
Bishop getting trapped or even h4 h5
stuff so this knight c6 move prior to
declaring your LightSquared Bishop sin
tensions has you know we're as black
you're putting some pressure on d4 so
you're threatening to play Bishop g4 and
on h3 take the knight out and then take
on d4 so this is the idea it's not
always a good a good idea to obstruct
the C pawn like this but this is the
idea behind it to put pressure on d4
with the knight with the bishop who
takes out a defender of d4
this knight c6 move coupled with rook to
b8 I now rook to b8 was suggested if
Bishop e2 was played let me put the
evaluation on right around here I know I
know stockfish 7 was pointing out on
Bishop e2 this rook to b8 move yeah I
know that this is a move and on push
you could calling for a knight to v4 but
thought you could also take and then
play Knight here it's another one but
yeah this this move here is so that b7
is defended if if now h3 you could
simply take and then take on d4 and
you're not dropping v2 simply up upon
with a strong night in the center so how
did it play out I took on c4 they
developed up to b8 it was just pointing
that out and now h3 so this is no good
as we saw takes on takes and now it's
upon advantage they take with the Queen
I'm just taking here takes again I'm on
the bishop I'm up upon b2 is defended
yeah black is doing well here so they
took with the pawn and now how could I
have done better
I played Bishop d6 here wants to go
straight in for Queen d7 immediately
observing these weakened squares around
the White King threatening to win the h3
pawn king g2 hmm not a move I would
really be considering so much a six ooh
the other idea is simply rook here
although as mentioned in the game I'd be
a bit hesitant to move this rook off of
the F file because of this pressure so
if the idea is to put a rock on the D
file I would be thinking more about the
B rook and I guess that this is
collapsing rook here does not allow me
to win the pawn right away because the
rook at the end would win the bishop
what is the great story with this a6
suggestion I don't know if I'd be able
to figure that out but I guess it's to
rattle the bishops post restrict the
bishops um you know how to commit to b3
or go back here where it releases
pressure against my king it's certainly
a slow idea could say that much you know
but I guess this is one of the points to
challenge the bishop eventually with b5
hmm also rules out Knight here observing
c7 but yeah pretty slow idea here okay
what did I do
I played Bishop d6 which isn't bad right
there Queen d7 oh yeah I didn't consider
that at all because of this no you don't
do that there's gotta be other there's
got to be other ways
fine nothing decisive certainly a
preference ear for black you know this
is fine drifting the night over here
Knight d5 when I got a d5 whether it's
g6 or d5 you're observing here and he's
better placed on d5 good grief
he's post up in the center anyway Knight
g6 Bishop there Knight age four on and a
half so now it is pretty serious I
thought after Bishop g4 I did have a
look at this you know what I didn't say
it in the game I did consider Knight to
h4 but I stopped my calculations right
here I thought I could play Knight f3
but I thought Bishop here it doesn't
work though
because I could take on g4 which
threatens to pretty serious things first
off mate and the other a fork of the
king and queen I thought about this I
didn't voice it and my calculation
stopped when I thought Bishop g5 could
be played and what am i doing now with
my knight on each floor just take the
bishop and I have these two in mind mmm
notice these are squares and just kind
of filtering in towards that white king
position and these weak squares and the
H file the F file these are the the big
weaknesses the G that's that's what the
Jeep on that's how valuable that Jeep on
is I mean what is he doing from his home
square he's watching over these two what
is he doing when he's on g3 it's
watching over these two four squares are
weakened by this capture
okay I went about it like this still
something no no it's not anything yeah I
just was not gonna allow this type of
thing to happen to my kingside so
alright now it's back to even and
anything missed around here I took was I
ever worse off yeah okay so I do have
that night g3 into e2 going for the
material but oh it's still complicated
this would have been tough Queen h4 huh
and then you have to see this h6
resource because if Queen takes I have
Queen here then I take with check and I
have to make some defensive moves here
to keep their Queen under control that
could be tricky to spot for sure this h6
resource well first off I don't know if
I even would have considered I don't
know if I would have even seen this
Queen h4 move hmm you know if you're
going straight in like this you're
getting mated in one and then two it's
not decisive but I mean I should have I
should have seen it and should have gone
in for it I'm pretty sure it's only
holding it as a half pawn advantage but
yeah pretty messy after Queen h4
h6 Bishop takes now I could take here
there is no Queen h7 right away messy
okay I didn't go for that
I played a6 no I'm suggesting you the
middle game now I'm doing it just to
stop Queen takes pawn but alright even
and we're both really low on time
around here how's the final position
looking is it winning for me once I have
this battery going on
no not winning but preference for black
calling for Bishop here pitching upon
you know I got some serious stuff lined
up on f1 f2 or f3 and it's not really
good way to stop the Queen invading on
any one of these three for example let's
say Queen this isn't working get to f2
Queen could guard two of these three but
not all three
so my queen will enter with check unless
they do something like this but I just
take play this one up upon rook ending
still potential for black to hold the
draw here okay well not the greatest end
to this but a very tense one as usual
out of this exchange French who would
have thought
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below
and as usual I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye